as many as half a million people are
preparing to march in Washington this
weekend a fight for stricter gun control
many of them will be high school
students the event follows a nationwide
walkout last week inspired by the school
shooting in parkland Florida students at
about 3,000 schools protested gun
violence since the deaths of 17 people
at Stoneman Douglas High School last
month
survivors have mobilized and never again
movement their goal is to overcome
political obstacles in effort to
influence gun legislation among the most
vocal students are seniors emma gonzales
and david hog both were featured last
night on 60 minutes and they join us
again at the table good morning
join us for the first time at the table
we are also looking forward to meeting
you both hello because everyone has been
praising you for your poise and your
intelligence and and your focus on this
have you all had a chance to really
reflect and and and really understand
what you all are doing and what it means
to the country do you think about that
Emma I personally do like a lot I think
about like in the future this is going
to happen like what we're fighting for
will happen because we're fighting so
strongly for it and we expect it to
happen now and with those expectations
we're gonna vote out the people who
aren't acting they've been calling you
to super here they've been calling your
group super heroes do you feel that I
don't think we're superheroes
I think we're whatever Americans should
be we're people that are standing up and
becoming politically active in our
democracy in our own way and I I think
what we saw last week with that walkout
as students were walking out of school
but now they're gonna walk into the
polls when they're able to vote and
they're gonna vote these people out of
office you said is that where it next
has to go though Emma because nothing
right now in response to the shooting
what's your response being about what's
happened legislatively in Florida and
then also at the national level one
thing has happened in Florida and that
was positive we got a bill signed and
that was good that's not gonna stop
there though because it's you know it's
just the beginning it's it was barely
anything it was important but as Jackie
said in 60 minutes it would not have
stopped what had happened at our school
were fighting for that change I think
what's important to realize with that
law too is there are a lot of loopholes
in it you can be 18 and buy a gun
privately still under that law and
a lot of gun purchases are purchased
that way and they it doesn't take care
of the gun show loophole it doesn't
require universal background check that
has 97% support among constituents it
doesn't cover so many basic things that
have a widespread support on both sides
of the aisle and that's the part that I
hate most about you know one thing that
stood out from your interview with 60
minutes was you called yourself the mass
shooting generation and you know you
think about the post 9/11 generation
right you really put it into context
what you a student's experience how has
that impacted you even before that that
deadly shooting how has that impacted
you on a day-to-day basis I think on a
day-to-day basis the fact that we even
have to talk about having active shooter
drills it's distracting from our school
life it's distracting from us just being
trying to be American kids and live our
own lives because they're turning our
schools into war zones and when we add
guns there I think we're just gonna make
it even worse even after we included all
this new legislation we required
training for all these teachers we
required psychological checks to make
sure that they're okay we made sure that
they were well trained and had
background checks why not just do that
for every single person I just want to
point out as a young woman it always
feels like you're living in a war zone
there's there's nothing that you can't
be oblivious to walking around in the
world no ma you wrote something very
moving in Harper's Bazaar you said my
name is Emma Gonzales I'm 18 years old
Cuban and bisexual I'm so indecisive
that I can't pick a favorite color I'm
allergic to 12 things but none of this
matters anymore
were the two of you involved in student
government before this happened no we
were science buddies to be honest we're
kind of we're kind of the Nerds of the
school I we're the last people that I
would ever expect well at least I am
Emma's always been an amazing person and
I think I even called the day before the
shooting not just to say because I just
finished up the documentary that's been
too much working on and she's played a
heavy role tonight and I realized really
what an amazing and dedicated person she
is and I just called her to tell her I
didn't know what she was going to do
next what I knew was going to change the
world the two of you along with others
became leaders of this movement did you
all get together did you all talk about
it immediately what happens so here's
what happened there I got a I got a text
that like well we're you know the day
the rally right yeah David's like these
guys are gonna take us out to dinner I'm
like all right so they're like we're
gonna pick up Cameron on the way and I'm
like cool Cameron kaske I know him he
was in Little Shop of Horrors and we
don't pick him up
he's not wearing pants he was like give
me one second and that was pretty much
that's the entire relationship with
Cameron are there it's like usually none
of us are usually wearing the right
amount clothes you're talking about
which role are you talking about him was
a rally where I gave the speech okay and
but but I mean but how did it come about
though that shortly after the shooting
that the two of you really became a
voice of this that's what I'm talking
about and very early on you had that
videotape yeah I think the way that we
really came about as a voice initially
the even the day of the shooting I I
went on news and did a lot
I did a hit with five million people
viewing live and then the next within
the next couple of days I was supposed
to be on the Anderson but the night I
was supposed to be on in again and they
didn't want me on there twice so I
called em I was like hey do you want to
go on there and that's where she did her
first live interview and what's the most
encouraging thing any politician has
said to you thank you actually I've just
been pretty cool and you know they're
throw up and some people on Twitter who
are like you know keep keep fighting out
there but they're not actually I don't
know the I know that the wheels of
bureaucracy turned very slowly but
they're not actually doing anything at
least that's what it feels like and I
feel like everybody needs to try harder
like politicians need to step up their
act you wrote and wrote and report kids
are acting like adults and adults are
acting like kids because kids have had
become a dirty word like you're acting
like children
that's offensive is to be called a child
and in fact we've been raised in this
school environment to reach it to show
what an adult should be we're being
raised and we're being pushed into the
real world so quickly we're never
learned how to balance a checkbook we
learn how to balance a checkbook in
fifth grade we're expected to know all
this stuff when we leave high school
just in case we don't make it to college
I think what's important to realize here
is that the one thing that the NRA is
trying to push right now is they're
trying to make sure that we forget about
this they expect our generation to have
a short attention span if we are not
going to let that happen because the
second that we forget about this it can
and it will be you which is one of the
reasons why you delayed the rally the
nationwide rally for
this coming up Saturday we've heard your
voices loud and clear what is your
message to other high school students
across the country who also are part of
the mass shooting generation I came out
there and vote yeah our message is make
sure that you get out there and vote
make sure that you are registered to
vote so you can vote in primaries and
make sure that you stay educated for the
rest of your life because the seeds of
corruption and greed are always being
sowed it's our duty as a democracy to
make sure that they don't spread you're
both getting death threats does that
deter you no I don't not at all I'm
gonna gets death threats at some point
in their life I feel be it from stalker
that's how we knew what we're doing
matters yeah people want to stop us
they're attacking us personally because
they can't find fault in our message
because from every single angle the
everybody knows on a certain level that
this is unacceptable and it was never it
should never have happened like for 20
years it should never have happened a
lot of people are listening to what you
all have to say
Emma Gonzalez David hog thank you very
much for coming to the table this
morning and then David as you know are
among the student activists featured in
the new CBS primetime documentary it's
called 39 days CBS News embedded with
the students in the weeks after the
Stoneman Douglas shooting as they turn
their grief into action the march for
our lives in Washington will take place
39 days after the tragedy and you can
watch 39 days Saturday in a Saturday
night at 9:00 8:00 central right here on
CBS